sometimes when donald trump does
something we call it humiliating but
it's only humiliating if you have a
certain sensibility
it's only humiliating if you have a
certain worldview donald trump last
night
gave an interview to fox news's sean
hannity that was so cringe-worthy
so disgusting that the humiliation
has spread much farther than you can
imagine sean hannity actually brought up
the story of donald trump allegedly
calling
dead soldiers who died in combat suckers
and losers
and donald trump focused in on the idea
that
it's not true that he didn't want to be
out in the reign in france and that
that's part of why donald trump didn't
go
that donald trump says i've been out in
the rain many times
and my hair gets wet and it's no big
deal this
is the level of discussion that is
happening with the president
uh of the united states on one of the
top-rated cable news shows we have a
raging pandemic with nearly 200 thousand
deaths
we have all sorts of economic problems
we are on the precipice of a major
election and donald trump is on cable
news saying
it's okay if my hair gets wet i made a
speech in the rain
no umbrellas know anything you know they
said it's just this information i didn't
want to get my hair wet i've had my hair
wet plenty of times
i made plenty of speeches in the rain
and if i wasn't
if i didn't you wouldn't be president
right now that i can tell you so
it's disinformation they made up a story
about two disgusting words that they say
i said
and i didn't and i have many witnesses
we have 21 witnesses they only have
sources
of course trump doesn't seem to realize
that a witness to something saying
you didn't say it is a weird thing if
someone comes forward and says i didn't
hear
trump say it that's not proof it wasn't
said
all it means is you didn't hear it and
it's it's very difficult of course to
prove
a negative that's by by its very nature
hard to do donald trump doesn't seem to
get that and he insists listen
zach said some guy named zach zack said
i didn't say it well that just means he
didn't hear you say it
earlier this week i reported to you that
donald trump's campaign
is tight on cash they have had to slow
down ad spending
in some key states the fundraising is a
problem
and sean hannity this is i mean this is
how you turn manure into gold or at
least
attempt to sean hannity hilariously
asked donald trump
is not buying ads a strategy like is not
having money maybe a strategy even check
this out
say that is not the case yeah a little
shy at 300 million dollars but
i was told by a friend in florida that
that joe biden has
three to one ads running against yours
is this a strategy you're waiting or
is this something that you didn't want
maybe you're just ramping up after labor
day
so four years ago i won it in the last
month
and we have about three times more cash
now than we had then and that's without
me putting up any of i needed extra i'll
put it up myself i just
i said that two days ago i said if
there's any necessary extra cash
but we have a lot of money coming in and
small donors i haven't been heavy on big
donors because i don't want to call them
you know when you call big donors you
you sort of put yourself in a very
compromising position
trump knows how compromising it
is to get money from donors because he
spent the last four years doing favors
to his donors
uh and it's very interesting to hear
donald trump say
we won it in the last month in 2016.
this is not a guarantee of anything of
course
joe biden's lead today today is 7.5
nationally hillary's lead on this day in
2016
was 2.7 so today joe biden's lead
is nearly three times as large as
hillary's was at this time
in 2016. it doesn't mean trump is going
to lose
but trump saying this year is just like
2016
is uh assuming a lot in 2016 donald
trump was not already the president
in 2016 donald trump was much closer
uh to his opponent than where he is
today that those are just
factual differences then donald trump
goes on to say
that right now the united states has
a record number of jobs what that means
is a question
you don't know what they're doing
frankly but they should all be open
and our country is doing very well we
have record numbers of jobs you saw the
numbers
just came out for the four months it's
the largest number
ever by far not even close so we do not
have a record number of jobs right now
donald trump has no idea what he's
talking about remember that
the big picture numbers are we lost
close to 50 million jobs during the
pandemic
many of those have come back okay but
we are still way down the idea that we
have more jobs than ever is something
that you have a tough time convincing a
12 year old of
even a smart nine-year-old probably
wouldn't fall for it but donald trump
throws out this generality we have the
record number of jobs it's very much
untrue
you're not going to hear any fact
checking of it from sean hannity
and then also continuing to spread what
at this point is just embarrassing
disinformation
donald trump claiming that if you look
at our coronavirus numbers
that they're actually amazing it's just
incredible how well we've done
it's two million two and a half million
maybe even more than that if we did it a
different way and
we've done a really good job but if you
look at our numbers our fatality numbers
compared to
other countries we're in we're in
really i mean it's amazing what we've
done we've been able to do something
that
a country especially with the kind of
size we're dealing with
we've done an incredible job the truth
there of course
is our numbers are really really bad
now if you don't adjust for our
population the u.s has by far the most
coronavirus deaths
but we also have a lot of people we
really need to be looking at per capita
numbers
on a per capita basis the united states
is 11th highest in the world out of more
than 200 countries and territories in
terms of deaths per capita
now if you take out some of these tiny
countries and territories which can skew
the numbers like
san marino and andorra the united states
has the ninth highest deaths per capita
from coronavirus in the world it's not
the lowest
it's not in the bottom half it is the
ninth
highest in the world question to you
when trump says this stuff when trump
says we have more jobs than ever
when trump says we have the best
coronavirus numbers in the world
do people believe it are there people
who hear trump say it and think
trump's right we've done such a great
job we're so much better off than every
other country
or is it just something he has to say
even if no one is going to believe it i
actually don't know the answer
i know there are people who do think
we're doing well on the virus
but i don't know that they think it
because donald trump is the one saying
it let me know your thoughts
and bigger picture does an interview
like this do trump any favors
is this a net gain for trump in some way
to be interviewed by sean hannity even
if he makes no sense
in ways that i can't exactly understand
does this do damage
or does it really not make a difference
whatsoever if you look at the the sort
of
uh framework of alan lichtman who
predicts elections using a qualitative
rather than quantitative system
he would argue i think that this doesn't
matter that really what impacts the
election
are big issues what is the status of the
economy
is there a major calamity etc there are
others
who may have a different perspective let
me know in general
do interviews like this have any impact
on the election results we would expect
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical